i had a hard time believing it when i
actually i like i need to go and
actually read
the legislation i went in and read it
and and it did just that to to
somehow believe that it is a good
thing to remove all references of mother
and father brother and sister
son and daughter from essentially
the administration of the house from the
legislative rules
uh it it it makes it not only does it
not make sense
it is a dangerous uh
step towards undermining you know
who we are and the existence of men and
women
joining me today is an army veteran a
former democratic u.s
presidential candidate and now former
congresswoman
tulsi gabbard welcome back to the reuben
report
hey good to see you dave always so
there's obviously a ton to talk about
here and a lot of stuff happening right
now
as we tape this but first off do i do i
have to refer to you as
former congresswoman do you keep being
called congresswoman forever
how does that work like when you're
mayor they always call you mr mayor or
mr president
are you congresswoman tulsi forever even
though you've stepped away
i think so but i i don't know the answer
to that my staff
uh former staff asked me that yesterday
i was like you know what i actually
don't know
the answer to that but uh tulsi
is always great tell us your work okay
so
look we're taping this right now as the
capital
is literally being stormed i mean that
is happening right now i know you were
seeing it right before we started just
as i was
um i wasn't planning on starting here
but
what do you make of what's going on
right now
i mean it's heartbreaking to see this
happening
at our nation's capital uh but it is
also
indicative this is a symptom of of much
deeper
issues and and challenges that have been
stewing for
a long time and and a lot especially as
of late over this last year
you know where this this conflict
culture that we
have seen growing in our society whether
it's online and now it's
being um embodied
or or actioned offline uh it
it results in something like this and so
so you've got to look at
uh what's driving this what's fueling it
you can look at politicians
uh political leaders who are more
interested in
uh fueling and and um
uh fueling divisiveness riling people up
for their own
personal or political benefit you see
the media doing the same thing for
ratings
uh you see big tech these big tech
monopolies and facebook using their
algorithms and social media
to continue to push and push and and put
fuel on the flames of this divisiveness
well
you see what is happening here today at
the united states capital before our
very eyes
is the manifestation of that that is the
symptom of these deeper problems and
from a leadership perspective i think
this is where
you've got to look to the kind of
leadership
we need but don't have in this country
right now which is leadership that puts
the well-being of the people and country
before themselves before political power
before their
their their selfish ambition are you
kind of shocked as someone that
that was in the government that just not
only our leadership in terms of
government
but our leadership sort of across the
board our academic leadership our
intellectual leadership you know there's
podcasters and
stuff like that but that we don't have
sort of like
a trusted group of people anymore that
kind of bring us together across the
board it
almost just simply doesn't exist anymore
i think that's right and i think that
it's become such a segmented thing where
you have
whether it's political leadership those
in the media or those in new media or
whatever it is you have these
these quote-unquote influencers that
are only speaking to their segment of
people who agree with them or believe
the same things that they believe
and uh and there's no exposure real
civil discourse or dialogue to people
who might have different views different
opinions different beliefs different
political
positions and and i think it's
it's not only not not a good thing for
our country
but it i think also contributes
especially when you're using this
divisive rhetoric and language
that can help uh fuel those who then get
riled up and say oh actually you know
what i'm gonna go take action on this
because those people
they are my enemy yeah that's the
dangerous thing
so does this what's happening right now
and then we'll move on to some other
stuff does it sort of feel like this was
inevitable in a weird way like once i
started seeing it this morning it was
just kind of like oh
yeah of course this is exactly what was
going to happen
and in a weird way it's almost like we
all deserve it for being part of it
or something like that well you know i
i was um gosh
months ago months ago was maybe one of a
few people who warned
of a civil war
if we continue down the path that we are
on
and i think that what we are seeing now
with this divisiveness that
that exists very much online
uh now being translated into action
further points in that direction
unless we as a country do something
about it we as the american people
we the as leaders in this country unless
we
shift course and and start uh
leading for the interests of the public
the american people
servant leadership leaders who are in
positions of power whether they're
elected or not elected saying i am here
to serve
this country and the american people not
my party
uh not my political interests not my
political ambition or or
selfish money whatever whatever that
selfish driver may be
we need servant leaders in place leading
with what we in hawaii call aloha you
and i have talked about this before
aloha is
saying hey i respect you i open my heart
and
and i love you as a fellow person as
a as a child of god as a fellow american
and whether we agree or disagree on
different issues whether we come from
different backgrounds or not
um we've got to be able to come together
on this shared common ground and work
for the the betterment and the
well-being
of the country and i think what do you
think uh go ahead
i was just going to say one last note on
on the danger of what we are seeing
playing out today
is uh this normalization of violence
where violence uh and and uh you know a
lot of the riots that we've seen over
the last year occurring that violence is
somehow okay if it aligns with
your view of what these people are
quote-unquote fighting for and that's
that's a very dangerous thing because
when i say leading with aloha i don't
mean just okay we're just going to sit
back and not do anything
leading with aloha means standing up and
fighting for what is right
but doing so within the construct of of
the institutions that we have in this
country
for example if you are concerned about
um the the legitimacy and the integrity
of our elections
take action to do something i introduced
a bill called the securing america's
election act
that if our country's leaders had passed
would have prevented a lot of the the
angst that people are feeling and seeing
right now with this election saying that
you have to have a paper
trail you have to have an auditable
paper backup for any electronic system
so that there's no doubt or question in
mind if
there has been a hack attempt or some
attempt to manipulate
our votes as voters if all of these
people in congress democrat and
republican
had taken that issue seriously and
passed that legislation those who are
now saying hey we have to stand up for
the entire why didn't you do something
about it before
you we do need to stand up and fight for
the well-being of this country
stand up for our constitution uphold it
but we need to do it in a way that is
constructive and within
the um institutions that have been set
up in this
society that is america so i have no
doubt that
probably every single person watching
this right now is agreeing with you and
going okay that all makes sense
i'm on board so tulsi why'd you get out
like you're exactly what we need right
like i i mean i've tweeted it a million
times
if tulsi gabbard was the future of the
democratic party i could honestly
consider myself a
democrat i can't do that anymore i don't
consider myself a republican
but what you just said there i think
most people agree with
yet at the same time you are getting out
so
tell me about that i had to make a
decision dave and i had to make a
decision
i made this decision last fall of 2019
as i was campaigning for president it
was uh
frankly a practical decision where i
could not both run for re-election to
congress and continue running for
president at the same time
and i made the decision to run for
president
uh it was a very serious decision that
was well thought through and i made the
decision that that
to continue that campaign for the
presidency because of the
the grave issues um that i was raising
in that campaign and the kind of change
in leadership that i really believe our
country needs
so um i'm going to continue to to fight
i may not be in congress anymore as of a
few days ago
but i'm going to continue to advocate
for freedom i'm going to continue to
advocate for common
sense solutions in our society and in
our government
and to continue to bring the truth to
the conversations that we as a country
should be having
so speaking of the truth i i i mean i'm
just putting my cards on the table i i
find you to be one of the last
you know i guess you're not a politician
anymore but one of the last somewhat
honest politicians
right like you're you're i sense that
you're really trying to do something
decent here
can you just talk about what it was like
to go
through the democratic machine during
the primary
process and go through the media machine
during that
you know the way the media treated you
and that that insane comment that
hillary made about you
and and and that little tussle that you
got in with kamala all of those things
while it was like i was seeing so many
people online
that were like you know i can't be a
democrat anymore but i kind of like her
like that's the direction
and yet the party the way the party in
effect treated you
yeah i we we could do we could do a
whole show just on this but i'll point
to
come on get on your soap box a couple of
a couple of the major takeaways that i
had from that experience
is um the the danger
and the threat that is posed to our
democracy
by the power of our political parties
both of them and the power that the
media
has you know a lot of people talk about
needing to reform
our money in politics and
and make sure that's more transparent i
agree with a lot of all those things
they are necessary but nobody points to
you know the the effect that the media
has
and you know the billions of dollars
that that exposure that narrative that
they're pushing
is worth in how they are filtering
what kind of information voters are
getting access to i'll throw big tech
in with this as well because they're
google facebook they're doing the exact
same thing and
deciding hey this is this or these are
the candidates who we want you to hear
from here's the narrative that we want
you to
hear or see and uh in my case
they they chose their narrative they
chose their candidates and and
ultimately they decided that they didn't
want
voters to hear from me but but who is
who is they because i feel like it
always comes down to this like certain
people will be like okay it's the
clinton machine that runs the democratic
party or maybe
that's kind of crumbling now it's more
the obama machine like when you say that
like that the party
didn't want you there in in effect or
big tech all the all those pieces like
who
is they do you think people ask me this
all the time i don't know that anyone
has a good answer
ultimately it is whether it's the the
people who hold these positions of power
literally
uh you know the heads of these um media
institutions these
these for-profit corporations who are
supposedly
uh you know generating news um but also
it's
it's both the uh people who are in
charge of political parties but also the
people who are
maybe more institutional people like the
clintons for example
um you know i i came and spoke the truth
about a lot of different issues from
our uh foreign policy and how
destructive
this foreign policy has been largely led
by
people like hillary clinton and others
and the cost that it has
carried both to soldiers and and friends
and veterans who who i know and who i've
served with but also to every single
american
uh bringing the truth and calling out
big tech calling out the media this is
something that they
felt um that they didn't want
to happen and uh so so those
those two areas really
um take away the opportunity whether
you're talking about the power the
political parties have through the money
that they're able to raise unlimited
amounts of money essentially and and
leverage those dollars
to pressure individuals members of
congress
state political parties to do what they
want as well as the power that the media
has these are the things that are
getting in the way of the american
people being able to get the truth
and to be shown hey here are the choices
that you have to vote for in this
election
let's have a fair hearing of what they
stand for what kind of leadership they
bring the qualifications experience that
they bring what kind of judgment they'll
exercise
uh frankly that that that's not
happening
that's not happening in our election so
speaking of the big tech thing are you
still
involved in that lawsuit with youtube
uh with google no um we ended up we
ended up having to
to uh drop the lawsuit actually no i
think uh
with that one i've been involved in a
couple here i think the google lawsuit
uh a judge
uh did not rule in our favor um
so that's something that legislatively
i've continued to push
uh through uh either abolishing or
reforming
section 230 so that big tech monopolies
like google and facebook
do not have this legal immunity that
allows them to do whatever they want
essentially and defying the whole
purpose of
of what section 230 uh was was created
for which was to say hey you know let's
let's have fair and neutral platforms
online for people to
kind of have this public square google
and facebook and others have
taken that and abused it and have turned
themselves into publishers
by picking and choosing what information
you know those online actually get to
see
and sequestering or censoring others you
know all about this yeah
i know a little bit and and but but
they're not held to the same standard
that the new york times is held to
where new york times picks and chooses
what stories what letters to the editor
what op-eds they choose because they are
publishers
these these big tech monopolies are
acting as publishers
but they're not held to the same legal
standard
that an any other publisher is held to
and those were the reforms that i was
pushing through my legislation
do you sense though that the ship has
probably just sailed on that i mean
trump was sort of
trying to do it and the republicans were
always threatening about it but they
don't you know and having hearings but
they just never did anything do you
sense that
there's just no reason i think i don't
think we should give i i don't think we
can give up this fight because there's
so much at stake here social media has
become
uh such a part of of so many people's
lives and as we are seeing here
today what is that what is happening at
the capitol where
uh you know the i know the updates are
still coming in but before we started i
saw there was at least one person shot
multiple capital police have been
injured
the the algorithms that the social media
companies are
using to intentionally manipulate
and control the information that their
users
are getting has a direct um
role to play in inciting this kind of
um frankly anarchy and violence that
that we're seeing and and so we can't
we can't just say well man you know it's
too late we can't um
we can't hold them accountable i think
we have to continue to push our leaders
those who on the one hand are saying hey
we're against censorship by big tech
but on the other hand are not backing
that up with action and actually passing
legislation
to do something about it i think it's
because a lot of them are getting a lot
of freaking money
from the facebooks and the googles at
their fundraisers that they're doing at
night and saying oh yeah you know don't
worry i'll just talk about it but we're
not actually going to do anything about
it
yeah so to that point when you were
doing congressional hearings on
quite literally anything did you often
feel and because i think a lot of people
now feel this way
that the whole thing is just theater
that it's not really how much of it is
that that you know cause i believe me i
watched enough of the social media stuff
especially and it's like there are guys
up there
saying things that i agree with on the
social media front especially ted cruz
kept hitting
the stuff that i really think is right
and yet i'm going
but nobody's doing anything so you're
saying okay
jack from twitter broke the law because
he lied under oath about shadow banning
or whatever the specific thing might be
but it's like no one does anything so
it's just like this dog and pony show
like oh we're all pretending to go to
work and then we have drinks together
and then that's it
yeah and so much of it is absolutely
political theater and just for show
and um i think that there's an
opportunity
to hold more leaders accountable given
how much
more access to you know through i think
this is where
social media can be used in a positive
way is to be able to
um not allow this kind of stuff to go
unchecked and say hey you know we're
yeah we're tracking so okay you're
complaining about this where's the bill
have you talked to your uh colleagues
about trying to pass this legislation
are you building support for it
rather than just saying okay well i'm
gonna i'm gonna put out a statement
and then fundraise off that statement
but not actually
uh do anything about and again this
elections thing i just keep
i keep going back to it because you know
we're living through it now and if all
the people who are complaining about it
now
had actually stepped up as leaders and
said okay we have a big election coming
up
let's fix these problems before the
election happens
there's there's bipartisan agreement
that this is a big issue
yeah it should have been fixed before
this this massive election in 2020 that
we all knew was coming
it's so interesting because i said on
the show this morning it's like i i'm
completely against violence political
violence either way for sure
full stop like no doubt and yet
the people that are doing some of this
stuff who've been called nazis and
racists who said okay
you know who see videos online of what
may be election tampering and all this
stuff and they're told they're not
supposed to see what they see or they
don't see it
or they're conspiracy theorists and then
we'll get to more of this in a moment
but like then we lock people in their
houses and we don't let them to go to
work
it's like that's what i mean when i said
earlier like it sort of all felt like it
was gonna end up here
in a weird sense that we've just ramped
up the crazy in so many ways that
well people people storming the capital
again not condoning it but it's like of
course it was going to happen
well we have to understand how we got
here and why we got here
i think one of the things that has has
so frustrated me
in our politics that i've seen
throughout my time in congress
uh is is how reactive our so-called
leaders are they're not actually leaders
who are
exercising uh good judgment and
foresight to see okay if we
do this then it's likely to end up
with a certain consequence
[Music]
and and in situations like this i think
we'll see a lot of reactions start to
come
out of it but probably not a whole lot
of introspection to say hey how did we
get here
so that we can make sure that we
shift course that we correct course and
try to get
back on track to prevent this kind of
situation from worsening
or happening again that that's really
where the leadership comes in
that we the american people need uh
we've needed all along and we especially
need at this moment
yeah so i want to go into a couple of
the things because you kind of went out
in a blaze of glory
just like saying everything that you
believe at least
a whole bunch of it at the very at the
very least and putting these bills
forward
and everything else but before we get
into the specifics of that
i'm curious do you do you sense that
someone like
you has a future in the democratic party
i i get your frustrations with democrat
republican left right and all that kind
of thing but
do you sense that sort of the more
moderate anti-war
don't want government doing absolutely
everything democrat does does that exist
anymore
it's becoming more and more rare
in uh in washington i think if
uh and i don't think that's this is a
recent phenomena
um but if i look at you know the
interactions that i've had with people
throughout my campaign for president uh
the conversations and and the social
media
and and and discussions that are
occurring across the country with people
scratching their heads at kind of the
crazy things that congress is choosing
to prioritize and take action on i think
that there are
there are a majority of people maybe
most people who
are hungry for some leadership based on
common sense
and leadership that values our
fundamental freedoms
as americans in the united states of
america
you know we're not all going to agree on
everything or maybe even many things
but i know that that we are
better when we are able to come together
and have honest and real discussions
uh even bringing our differences to the
table when we are centered and focused
on
what we can do together for the
betterment of our country so do you
sense though that can happen with kind
of the new wing of the democrats like i
don't know if you were ever in like a
sit down with
aoc and and ilhan and rashida and the
rest of them
but do you sense if you came in like on
on what i would call
your extremely moderate position on
abortion that almost
everyone on the left would have agreed
with you know
literally five years ago certainly ten
years ago
where now you would just be call you'd
be called an evil republican or an evil
conservative or or worse for having that
position do you sense that they're
willing to have those conversations i
don't think it's the moderates that are
having the problem with the conversation
i don't i don't think i don't think that
there is really
even an interest there sadly um
i i think that that it's indicative of
of a group of people who
are uh you know you're either all or
nothing you are you are either
pure enough in their eyes whatever that
means and whatever barometer with which
they're choosing to measure a person by
um or you're cancelled
i think that's that's uh you know and
it's a dangerous
it's a dangerous place and something
that doesn't represent
um the the freedom of thought and the
freedom of speech that that we should
celebrate in this country so with that
in mind i saw an awful lot of people on
twitter and although i do say twitter
is not real life i saw a lot of people
when you were campaigning saying man
if tulsi would just say she's a
republican she'd
she'd be she'd have a lot more support
that in essence you would be sort of a
more libertarian-minded
centrist republicans something like that
and again i get it
the two-party thing and all that but if
you were to have a political future like
would that make some sense to you
it's not something i've given thought to
and i don't know you know i think again
i point to some deeper deeper um
challenges that we need to address as a
people and as a country and that we need
to
uh look to our leaders to bring about
this
this deeper kind of spiritual change
that's got to come from the heart
where there's a shift towards working
for and serving
the people rather than purely
being motivated by uh political ambition
greed
power and and all the the selfishness
that that frankly is driving so much of
our politics today
yeah can you talk a little bit more
about how your faith plays a role in
this because
it's it's pretty rare to hear anyone
that's
that's thought of as somewhat left to to
talk about faith and i know even
during christmas week and a few times
over the last couple months you've
tweeted out a few things
a little bit talking about your faith
and and i do sense we're in some sort of
very odd
spiritual war right now you know it's
not like my favorite language but we are
in some thing
where everyone's obsessed with politics
but that's really just a replacement for
something else
you know this is my my for me personally
you know my
uh relationship with god and my
my striving daily to develop um
my love for god and and to be pleasing
to god by serving and taking care of
god's children and protecting our planet
this is what motivates me
in my life and
regardless of the name with which people
choose
to call god or how one worships god or
whatever this is not about religion or
one religion versus another one sect
versus another
um this is to me about the recognition
uh in a very deep way of of who
we are and seeing past
all of the different labels that are so
often used
to divide us and and if we see each
other for who we are that we are all
children of god regardless of all of the
things that
that again those labels those things
that are used to put us
in different boxes then we can come from
a place as individuals and especially as
leaders in this country who carry a
great responsibility
to make an impact on people's lives
positive or
negative when we come from this very
deep spiritual place of a recognition of
who we are
then we're motivated
by the most perfect uh motivation which
which is really truly to care for each
other
and to help each other to to help make
that positive impact from wherever we
sit whether you're sitting in the halls
of congress
or sitting as we are in a conversation
uh here today
good god i can't believe they went with
kamala instead of you
it's making me all right well with
with that in mind i think you you tried
to add a little honesty and and decency
and everything that you just described
in your last few weeks in congress so i
want to go through a few of the things
that you were you were really talking
about and trying to make happen
uh let's talk about the covid vaccine
because you've been pretty outspoken
about how we've we've really butchered
some of what we're doing here
in terms of the rollout this this may
shock people but i really
strongly have been pushing our cdc
and their advisory committees as well as
our state leadership here in hawaii
leaders across the country to make their
decisions based on medical science
about who should receive this vax who
what's the priority
given the limited amount of vaccine
available who needs to receive it first
if you look at medical science you would
find that
based on the all of the trials that have
been done it has been scientifically
established that this vaccine
is effective in preventing serious
health complications from covid
and even death it has not been
scientifically established that this
vaccine is effective
in um stopping this virus from being
transmitted from one person
to another so if you look at both of
those
facts that have been scientifically
established you would draw the
conclusion that
the first priority of people who should
get this vaccine
are our frontline health care workers
and elderly americans those who are over
65 years of age and who have been proven
throughout this entire
pandemic are many many times more likely
to die
if they get this virus than those who
are younger
and healthy unfortunately
the recommendations that are coming out
of the cdc do not reflect
what has been established by science and
this is the warning that
that i'm calling out right so what is
that what's their way or what
essentially is they they have um
they're making politically driven
decisions that are essentially putting
the lives of elderly american seniors
at risk where they're saying okay well
yes frontline healthcare workers are
getting it first as they should right
now
but those who are getting it next are
people who they deem as essential
workers which is about 87 million
americans and those who
fall under everything from
uh people who are working at the grocery
store people who are manning the
the cash register at a liquor store to
lawyers to people working in the media
to people working in transportation
construction corrections there's
essentially a laundry list of people who
they have deemed as essential workers
um of any age who who they're saying
should either get the vaccine before our
seniors or who our seniors need to
compete with
in order to get this vaccine and this is
what is
is uh it's it's just mind-boggling
because
this is coming from people who claim to
be medical experts
but they're not making their decisions
based on science they're instead
making politically motivated decisions
where do you fall
generally on lockdowns and the rest of
it i mean you know we're coming up
unbelievably on basically almost a year
i mean it's been about 10 months already
of sort of lockdowns masks the whole
thing we were told two weeks to flatten
the curve
and now we're being told oh maybe a
hundred day
federal mass mandate i'm in california
where
everything is locked down i mean the
main street i live off of
it looks like a ghost town i mean it
genuinely looks like a ghost town
do you believe this should have been
left to the states and are you kind of
shocked at how it's now 10 months later
and we kind of forget
where we started from um
i mean there's no question that this is
a this is a major public health
issue given not only how infectious this
virus is but also the recent mutation
that we've seen occur in in the uk and
other places and now i think colorado
has gotten the first view
of an even more infectious version of
kovid
so i think that they're you know the
baseline standard of public health
precautions do need to be taken
uh which you know it is it's it's you
know wear masks protect yourself protect
others and and wash your hands and
socially distance
um the the lack of a national strategy
with regards to
testing has worsened the situation where
still as we sit here today it is
incredibly difficult
to get a test if you test more
frequently and more people then you have
the ability for people to act on that
information and take precautions
themselves there's no reason why we
shouldn't have these capabilities
deployed
all across the country there's no reason
why we shouldn't have medical grade
masks available to every american which
are actually
most effective versus the cloth masks
that so many people are forced to use
because they can't get medical masks
and then um you know the issue with
the nonsensical decisions that a lot of
state and local leaders are making for
example in california i saw
i think it's a viral video at this point
where this guy is out paddle boarding in
the water by himself
and was apprehended by police both in
the water and
on land how does that make any sense we
had here locally there was a decision
made for a while like
no one's allowed to go outdoors no one
is allowed to leave your home
unless for you know you're going to the
doctor you're going to the grocery store
but we know that people who are how's
the weather in hawaii again
usually pretty sunny pretty sunny
which we know is better for you know
increasing your immunity
exercise is good for you uh they said
okay well we'll let people out but
like uh we'll open up the hikes again
but you can only go by yourself
you can't go with anybody like okay so i
can't go hiking with my husband
we live together um and how safe is it
for and one person to go out on a hike
in the mountains by them
but i mean it's just you can there's so
many different examples of of
really nonsensical decisions that again
have not been made based on
science and and how best to help protect
our communities and protect people's
health and well-being and the more and
then of course the last i'll mention is
how
we are all told nationally by these
so-called medical experts that
uh gathering in large groups of people
creates a great harm and a great risk
but all of a sudden if there is a a mass
gathering
for a political purpose that these
experts agree with then it's okay
and it's fine and and so there's no
surprise in my mind why so many people
are throwing like the bs flag on the
field
and saying you know i i don't trust you
guys i don't trust you guys how can we
trust what you are telling us
is true and that this will actually help
protect our neighbors and friends and
community
when there's there's no consistency and
these decisions are not being made
based on proven medical science what do
you think just sort of philosophically
about
lockdowns in general i mean they haven't
been proven to work
california is clearly an example of that
i spent last week in florida where
everything was open and the numbers are
are actually less and people are out
there and they're living their lives
but philosophically just sort of the
amount of people that we've just put out
of work and we know depression is up and
alcoholism is up and drug use is up and
and all of this stuff um
it's almost like people are just kind of
forgetting what freedom is like you
really within 10 months you can
completely forget it
yeah i think that there's i don't think
that one can say
yes lockdowns or no lockdowns as a broad
statement i think that there are
certain things that that could and
should be done in a public health crisis
like the one that we are seeing to try
to contain a virus
like this but again those decisions
should be made based on
uh the science and what we know will be
most effective
i think one of the ineffective things
that we've seen occur
is how big box retailers for example
have been allowed to remain completely
open and conducting their business
as per usual with large numbers of
people going in and out
every single day and yet you know the
small mom and pop shop on the on the
corner
has been forced to shut down because
they are they are not essential
this this how are you choosing who is
essential and non-essential who gets to
stay open and who gets to close
and frankly it's been the biggest
corporations
who have benefited the most who've been
allowed to stay open
throughout this pandemic whereas the the
small businesses the restaurants and and
small shops in our communities
have not been allowed to open
their doors uh again points to
politically motivated decisions rather
than decisions made in the best interest
of the people
do you think we ever get back to
something that will feel like the good
old days of
february of last year meaning that even
if tomorrow they said okay we cured this
thing everyone's got the vaccine we're
good
that just because of sort of what you
talked before this we're in sort of an
information war people are so
untrustworthy of
of uh sources that people just either
won't go out
or they if you were a businessman how
would you say okay i'm going to open a
restaurant now like you would you would
it's hard
90 of restaurants i think fail in the
first year anyway
like how would you take the risk to go
out and do that stuff like it seems to
me that
the normal people are like oh we'll get
back to normal
i don't think so a friend of mine
recently
had had the guts to open a restaurant uh
just a few months ago there in southern
california oh man
and i've been keeping in touch with him
they've had to shut down a couple of
times because of
uh someone came in and had tested
positive and had to go through all of
the things to make sure that everyone
was okay
but but you know they're losing
something like fifteen thousand dollars
a day
uh just just to keep the doors open and
they're trying to persevere through and
i know there are so many others who
are either doing the same or who have
not been able to sustain
that kind of loss
it's hard it's hard to say at this point
i i think that
you know even going beyond what you're
talking about just the basic
level of consciousness now about hygiene
and um health and other things
are changing the way that we will all
view you know live our lives and the
kinds of things that we do i think that
i think some of the things that we've
seen in asia where people wear masks a
lot more
uh just by choice i think that's
something we'll probably see especially
for those who travel i know i
i was wearing masks on airplanes before
this pandemic began just because it's
like uh you know
you don't know who's on the plane
there's a lot of sick people and i don't
want to get sick
you mean you were wearing a mess before
it was cool
i i i will wear that badge with pride
all right so let's let's jump through a
couple of the other things that you did
because i think it gets to my point
that there there was a a moderate sane
democrat at one point and unfortunately
she's not in congress anymore
uh they they just passed this gendered
language situation in the house of
representatives they're removing
gendered language which nancy pelosi
pushed through
although hilariously i i think it's
still in her twitter bio that she's a
mother and a grandmother which are both
gendered terms but they want in essence
their taking gendered terms
should not be used in the house of
representatives anymore and
you you were trying at least to get that
to not happen
uh yeah i i had a hard time believing it
when i actually i like i need to go and
actually read the legislation i went in
and read it and
and it did just that to to somehow
believe
that it is a good thing to remove all
references of mother and father
brother and sister son and daughter from
essentially the the administration of
the house from the legislative rules
uh it it it makes it not only does it
not make sense
it is a dangerous uh
step towards undermining you know
who we are and the existence of men and
women
and and this is where i see such great
hypocrisy is that this is coming from so
many people who
proudly proclaim that they are champions
of rights
for women how can you
claim that while simultaneously taking
steps to undermine
the fact that a biological woman exists
and i again like we can we can take this
back directly to
science and biology and and um
you know this this is something that uh
more people should be talking about and
not
running away from but even putting aside
the like the specifics of it
just the fact that there's so much going
on in the country right now
and that any legislator actually spent
10 seconds crafting this nonsense while
there's so much
more important stuff to deal with that
as someone in
congress must have drove you crazy
because i'm sure you saw all sorts of
things like this over the years
you know i introduced a resolution one
of the bills that i introduced right
before i left
uh with congressman green a republican
and a fellow veteran
that basically said hey we as congress
need to take action to make sure that
the cdc
immediately starts to make sure this
vaccine is available to our elderly
americans
who are dying at higher rates than
anyone else from covid
if there is a first act that congress
this new congress could have and should
have taken
it should have been that yeah by
recognizing that people's lives are at
stake and we have the opportunity
potentially to help save people's lives
how about that be getting your
priorities straight
and putting the lives of the american
people our elders our moms and dads and
grandparents first
what do you think pelosi would say if
you if she was watching this right now
if she's sitting next to you right now
and you said to her
well why did you bother doing this right
now what do you think she would say
i i don't know to be honest i i don't
know what she would say
it uh um
i don't know i don't know but the fact
the fact that this action
was not an obvious one to take coming
right out of the gate
coming out of the new year where every
single day people are concerned
about their parents and grandparents and
when they can get the vaccine so they
can
not be imprisoned in their homes they
can go out they can go to the doctor
they can go and see and spend time with
their families
the fact that that was not the obvious
first choice i think
really says it all yeah well it's sort
of a perfect segue because you also
tried to put forth this trans athlete
bill and for some reason the trans issue
and particularly related to sports this
has become like the third rail thing you
can't touch it if you even say
anything remotely close to what you just
said that there are
biological differences between men and
women you'll be called to transphobe and
and everything else
um but you put forth a bill to
in effect say yes there there are some
differences and we have to acknowledge
it
and and for those who actually read the
bill and it's not that long i know
this is this is uh usually a thing
people like oh this bill does this like
actually just read it
it's it's pretty simple and very direct
and straightforward and
it basically it doesn't mention uh
trans people at all it is called the
protect
women's sports act i introduced it with
my republican friend mark wayne mullen
who has
three little girls who love to wrestle
uh the the oldest lara is 12 the the
younger twins are 10. they all love to
wrestle and they're really good at it
and he recognizes that it would be
neither fair nor safe
for his little girls to go and compete
on a mat against a biological
boy there are physiological differences
that exist between boys and girls and
men and women
and when you look to and this is what
our bill does it clarifies upholds and
strengthens title ix
which was enacted in 1972 out of that
recognition
that there are biological and
physiological distinctions between
boys and girls men and women and
title ix ensures that girls and women
are able to
play in sports and compete in sports on
a level
playing field title ix is
is being undermined and weakened in some
areas as states
are are interpreting what it does
in very different ways and as a result
as we've seen in places like connecticut
you have girls who are you know they're
about to graduate from high school
they're vying for scholarships to
college and
and losing um in track and field
competitions
because they have all of a sudden now
been faced with a competitor who has a
very direct physiological advantage as a
biological
male and they're seeing their
scholarship hopes and dreams
be taken away from them and so this
really just says hey this is about
making sure that all of those
opportunities that were
were provided to women and girls because
title ix was in place
are allowed to continue for this
generation
and the next it doesn't discriminate
against anyone it just simply says if
you're a biological female you shouldn't
be forced to compete in sports against a
biological male
do you want to make any comments about
trans people before the haters get in
here because i know you have no problem
with trans people but i know that
they'll hear what you just said
and say she's a transphobe so do you
want to just just
clean it up for them before they get to
it i i think that people
are allowed and free to be able to make
their own choices and live in this
country as americans
and be treated uh justly under the laws
as we all are
if you if you again look at my
legislation you'll recognize that this
very simply points to
biological differences between men and
women and upholds
the incredible game-changing and
life-changing opportunities
that title nine created back in the
early 70s
all right so the next one that you went
for because you really just pulled out
all the stops on on your way out the
door
um you you tried to pass an abortion
bill
and we have a similar we talked about
abortion last time you're on the show
and we have a similar stance on it my
my position before i wrote my book was
was 20 weeks because at that point we
know that the fetus can feel pain
now there's actually a little evidence
that it's closer to 18 weeks
but then in my book i took the first
trimester position which is
you know about 12 weeks in effect and i
talk about i concede that i believe it's
a life i
tried to talk about as many of the moral
and philosophical and religious
issues and all of those things i think
you know that david and i are in the
midst of
surrogacy right now so i i'm like well
aware of
all of the stuff related to this right
um
you put forth a bill that as i said
earlier
was the democratic position for pretty
much the last
three decades or so but is not the
democratic position anymore so can you
lay it out for us
sure it is um i introduced two bills
one is the late term abortion ban
act and the other is the uh
born alive survivors protection
act um you know there there were
similar pieces of legislation that were
introduced previously
in congress that uh had some some
issues some minor issues with the bill
that i felt that i needed to vote
against it for example the late term
abortion act
there had been a similar bill that was
introduced previously
um that provided an exception to the
bill
if the life of the mother was at stake
but it did not allow for any exception
if there were severe uh
and irreversible health and physical
consequences
at stake for the mother so the bill that
i introduced
so i felt that i had to oppose it at
that time because it did not provide
that exception the bill that i
introduced included that
essentially um uh
but but was was mostly the the same as
as the other bill um and and the the the
the born alive for for babies who are
born alive
even after an attempted abortion um
there are laws in place that should be
strengthened to make sure
that any doctor and health care provider
in that situation
must do all that they can to save that
baby's life
no matter how that baby got to that
situation just as they would be required
to do
under law for a baby that was born
prematurely maybe at that same at that
same age
you know to to me these are our
bills that every american frankly should
support
right so i i could get not supporting it
if you were completely
against abortion because you just
wouldn't want those bills to exist but
but for the
group of people that have you know some
gray area there
um what what's your actual position on
the on the cutoff your first trimester
also if i'm not mistaken
um uh the bill is 20 weeks it it is
it is modeled after as you mentioned
there's there's been a lot of science
that's based around
um when the baby can can start
to feel pain and uh that's what the bill
is based on
yeah do you find that even on abortion
that it's easier in an odd way to talk
to republicans like i think the average
republican or conservative let's say
is going to disagree with you on this
they absolutely disagree with me on this
the amount of letters that i got saying
dave i love your book you're wrong on
abortion but it's okay like
but they'll you know we can agree to
disagree do you find that even people
who completely
disagree with you on this on the right
are still willing to talk to you about
it where to
to take that 20 week position on the
left
is pretty much impossible these days
yeah which is unfortunate i mean for for
me personally i
i am personally pro-life i would never
make that choice to have an abortion uh
you know it's it's often one of the most
difficult
decisions that that any woman may make
in her life
and it really comes down to you know
what role does the government have
uh to to play into this and so this this
is a much
much bigger topic that that we as
americans
should come together and and talk about
and discuss
because when you implement laws there
are
consequences that come with those laws
and there's a country i believe it might
have i think it was argentina
might be mistaken a south american
country that for example had very strict
laws in place where
they ended up actually arresting
women who had had miscarriages
because it was a violation of their
their anti-abortion laws so
we've got to go through um this question
you know morally as a society and the
decision that people are making for
themselves
and the impacts of that personally but
also
what role government should have uh
in this incredibly uh personal decision
that a woman that a woman uh may make
for herself
and her family uh so
i i've seen just just going back to your
question you know
yeah i mean there are democrats and
people who consider themselves
progressives who
um really believe that there should be
no restrictions
whatsoever on abortion i completely
disagree with that i think that that
uh to a certain point women need to be
able to make
this decision for themselves but there
should be
very clear restrictions in place and
that we as a society
should come together to find ways to um
make it so that this is a rare decision
that is that is put in place and
unfortunately
that's not something that is
being pushed uh especially by democrats
yeah and that's so unfortunate because
it's like man if you guys would just
show us a little of that gray area you
could still keep people but i always you
know i've debated abortion
with plenty of pro-life people on my
show ben shapiro and dennis prager and a
whole bunch of others and i always say
to them at the end
you know you guys make compelling
arguments but in a weird way
it's the craziness of the left that has
made me slightly more pro-life because
if you're going to tell me you can have
an abortion at eight months
i i just can't get there no
i agree yeah um let's do a little bit of
uh future stuff
before before we let you go so first
we'll do some quick political stuff then
i want to do some
some personal stuff so all right it does
look glad that like joe biden
will be the president kamala harris will
be vice president
do you sense despite everything we've
talked about here and obviously what's
unfolding in dc right now
that this idea of healing i know you
want it to happen but you know we're
being told now it's the time to heal and
all of this stuff
do you sense that we're really going to
get there or is it just
kind of you know a little bit of lip
service
for now uh i think the the jury is is
still out
right now again i i very much hope
that we see a major shift uh
in our leadership and and yes the the
tone that the president
sets is very important but it's got to
be bigger and and more far-reaching
than that so you know we'll we'll see
what happens there
[Music]
we'll see what happens through the
nomination process the the kinds of
people that we've seen
biden choose as his nominees to serve in
his cabinet
to me some of the problems that i see
very directly
are that many of them represent the same
kind of
corruption and watching legal corruption
in washington that that we've seen for a
long time where you have
people who rotate through this revolving
door of working in government then you
go work as a lobbyist then you go get
money from a defense
contractor then you go back in and work
in the department of defense and
this is what we see and who he's
nominated uh to serve as secretary of
defense he
was yanked off the board of raytheon to
go
and now be the nominee for secretary of
defense you
see this with uh the secretary of state
nominee tony blinken
uh who's just made a whole bunch of
money from defense contractors
uh in the time between the biden
administration or the
obama administration and and now uh
what to speak of the policies that a lot
of these folks represent which
are really centered around looking at
their track records
continuing these costly war-mongering
regime change
interventions that have proven to be
incredibly destructive
and costly both for us here in this
country our troops our people
as well as the people in the countries
where these wars uh
have been waged and that's uh something
that that's of serious concern to me and
again something that
i'm going to continue to be very vocal
on trying to shift
our country's policy into one that
actually works best for our country the
american people and for peace
and security i think what you just said
there is that the swamp is real
in effect when people talk about the
swamp this rotating group of people that
come in and out and
never really kind of kind of do much of
anything all right so that that's the
political part
um but what about for you personally
because uh
i know people would love to have you
back in politics i know you want to take
a little break and and do some other
things
what what's going on with tulsi
um i'm in hawaii right now uh i am going
to go see
why
um yeah look i i i don't i don't know
specifically yet
um but i do know that i am going to be
continuing to be a strong voice and a
strong advocate
for uh you know a lot of these issues
that we're talking about that really
center
around upholding our fundamental
freedoms as americans in this country
that are
are under threat that we cannot take for
granted
continuing to push for and advocate for
common sense policies and solutions
and frankly just conversations where we
can bring people together who may have
different views and backgrounds
and have a sincere exchange of ideas
based on respect
in that spirit of aloha of really caring
for each other and caring for the future
of this country and the world
for that matter that feels like a good
ending to me what about you
i think so i think so there's no better
way to close
open and close the conversation than
aloha there you go
all right well it was good seeing you or
whatever these
digital things are i i hope i'm going to
work on getting out to hawaii i do need
a little escape from california so
i'm going to work i think so i'm going
to work on that uh but good luck with
that we know
we'll go out in the water you know i've
only surfed once so you're going to have
some serious you got some teaching
skills i know you do
i do i do you'll be in good hands trust
me
i do have a tor i have a torn acl in my
knee but that's a that's a separation
you'll be fine
all right tulsi thanks so much for doing
this and i look forward to
seeing what's next thank you if you're
looking for more honest and thoughtful
conversations about politics instead of
non-stop yelling check out our politics
playlist and if you want to watch full
interviews on a variety of topics watch
our full episode playlist
all right over here and to get notified
of all future videos be sure to
subscribe and click the notification
bell